my son sacrificed his life to save me  his powers  are not a gift  but a curse  mourn out of Rage  [Music]  I don't know  this Loose Cannon needs to be locked  down before innocent people start  getting hurt  it's been asleep for 5 000 years  and find us a cell that can hold them  they'll take care of the grass who's on  the team  I didn't bring a passport we don't need  passports  we're the Justice Society  we're here to negotiate your peaceful  surrender  I'm not peaceful  nor do I Surrender  here we go  I kneel before no one  you didn't come here to seek Justice  we came to exact Revenge  [Music]  I never said I was a hero  you if you are not worthy  but fate does not make  you  sad when they say  you had two parts  [Music]  destroyer of this world  [Music]  or you can be its savior